In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for June 23rd, on which we commemorate the Holy
Marjor Agrippina.
On the 23rd of the month we celebrate the memory of the Holy Marjor Agrippina and her
companions, Paula, Bassa, and Agathonica.
The Holy and Glorious Marjor Agrippina was born and brought up in Rome, in a noble family.
From her youth she consecrated herself to God, and by the sweetest savor of her virtues
procured for the Christians a foretaste of the delights of paradise, urging them to renounce
the passions and then choose the path of purity and virginity, so that a large number of
girls and mature women asked to share her way of life in order to inherit the grace that
God had given her.
But the lustre of her virtues provoked the envious hatred of the pagans, who denounced her
to the authorities during the time of Valerian's persecution in 257.
Accused of rebellion against the institution of marriage and of having fraudulently imposed
on young girls, the betrothed of Christ replied that, far from having turned them aside,
she had presented them to God, and that the virginity that she extolled was not a breakdown
of society, but union with the Savior, who came into the world born of a virgin.
She generously gave herself over to martyrdom for love of her heavenly spouse.
Back on the mouth, she kept silence, baffling all the dead bones of impiety.
Stripped and flogged till her blood soaked the ground, she exposed the profiteous machinations
of the enemy, and her limbs locked in fetters.
She unraveled all the illusions of the pagans.
Finally, after having been visited by an angel who healed her wounds and having appeared
once more with assurance before the tribunal, she gave her soul into God's hands during the
torture and carried off to heaven the crown of victory.
Her friends and spiritual sisters, Bassa, Paula, and Agathonica, who had followed her trial
in peril of their lives, were later able to take her body that had been left in the field
for the dogs, and moving on from place to place, guided at night by a pillar of light,
they arrived in Sicily, and laid it in a place called Menis, where they built a church
in honor of Christ's holy martyr.
Her presence immediately drove out the demons that were worshipped as gods by the people living
on the island, and thus delivered them from the darkness of error.
Parasene pirates having dared to attack the church, they were slain by the appearing
of a golden dove carrying a cross, lepers, and people with all sorts of sicknesses who
came to venerate the body of Saint Agripina, were delivered from their ills.
Bassa and Agathonica were also found worthy of the crown of martyrdom.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us,
and save us.